[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
thank you
Tucker Carlson and Andrew Tate
of a bunch of [__]
oh my God I I can't even tell you how
ridiculous this is that we even have to
[__] talk about this Twitter's down
this morning
sort of and kinda so we're probably
going to look at Twitter and threads
today both
together
like as Twitter stays down we'll look at
threads I want to show you some of the
uh
the committee meeting right now with
director Ray the FBI director who was
appointed by Donald Trump
I don't know why we have to keep going
through this again this goes back to the
white male for agility [__]
this is the same old [__] story these
fragile white men you know what they're
really pissed off about
like and I'm going to show you a clip of
this Andrew Tate Tucker Carlson
interview and the only reason why is be
that I am going to show it to you
as much as I don't want to
is because you're
you got to know where these [__]
chuckleheads are getting this garbage
you gotta know where they're getting
this word salad white male fragility I
want to be masculine and I'm oppressed
and I don't want to compete against
women because women are better than men
type [__] because that's the truth
that's what they're really pissed off
about that's what they're really mad
about it's why they want to turn the
clock back these Nazis like Nick Fuentes
others the America First Nazi party
Trump himself this Andrew Tate and
Tucker Carlson when they're like oh the
good old days when men didn't have to
compete with women like that's what
they're really [__] scared of right I
think about it think about it like if if
you were in a wall climbing contest
right
white men in this country would have a
25-foot ladder to climb a 15-foot wall
women would have [__] weights chained
to their ankles
and the men are still bitching about
competing because the women are bitter
that's why because they make it up the
wall faster they stand around bitching
about how oh this ladder isn't good
enough for me
it's not good enough look at this ladder
who made this let what skin color was
the person who made this letter and then
they go on and on about how they're
oppressed because they don't have a good
enough ladder why the woman is halfway
up the wall with thousands of pounds of
Weights chained around her ankle
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
that you're you have pain and suffering
listen this is the other [__] thing
listen I was in high school during 9 11.
okay I was prime age to join the
military I decided to start a family
instead
and I'm thankful for that
I I'm thankful that other people
volunteered to go fight so that I could
stay here work and have a family
I appreciate that that means that means
the world to me that that they did that
so that people like me could stay here
and have a family
but there's two generations
two generations of spoiled ass white
dudes and dudes in general who weren't
forced to go to war in a draft
two generations
two
and they're bitching about pain and
suffering get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense
you bunch of God damn [__]
thinking thinking that tanning your
balls and making money makes you a man
that's what this that's what the whole
[__] thing is
that's what the whole [__] interview
is and that's what Andrew Tate and
Tucker Carlson's personality is ah wolf
you don't have enough money
to buy a Ferrari to impress women listen
I don't know if you guys have talked to
women before now when I mean talk I mean
like listen you know like let them tell
you [__] and you listen and you like
actually engage in what they're saying
not just look at their tits while
they're saying it okay
most women don't give a [__] if you own
a Ferrari or not you dumb son of a [__]
most women don't see a Ferrari as the
mark of a man
you dumb bastard
nor do they count how many how many
ones you got in your bank account
neither
there's a lot more that goes into being
a man than money
and how tan your balls are
and this is coming from a man who
doesn't know [__] about it
oh [__]
and it's you know this is where this
trumpism [__] comes from this is where I
showed you that guy yesterday the little
the little nincompoop on Twitter the
little twig he was flexing in front of
his camera in his mom's basement
he's like oh I am I am the I
was your perfect white man this is
exactly what the world needs
come on man
no no woman looked at that and went yeah
oh boy
that gets me excited
not one
not one show them to me give me an
example send it and I'll retract my
comment
but this is where this stupid [__] boils
up from this is where this is how they
breed fascism into these [__]
boneheads minds
is that you are superior just because
you are you that's so stupid
that's so stupid what an ignorant
[__] what an ignorant world view in
2023 to think that you're Superior
because you got a certain set of
genitalia and by the way by the way
speaking of Andrew Tate and him being
really
um feel really oppressed about being a
man look Andrew we get it you want to be
a woman and you don't want to compete
anymore as a man so you should
transition and then and then you can
deal with uh you know other things like
being marginalized you know wanting to
be eradicated by legislation in this
country forced at a public because you
can't you don't know what the [__]
facility to use because they pass all
kinds of laws to make it really [__]
confusing
because they don't want you in public
they don't want to see you I mean we
don't want to see you now but they
definitely won't want to see you then
maybe you should try that on for size
you [__] twit oh by the way did you
know did you know that Andrew Tate is in
jail for sex trafficking
I I well man it's like it's like they
miss that
the other thing about this interview
that is really confusing
it's really confusing to me
I'm not sure why and this must be a new
trend
it might be a new dress I don't I don't
know
hey I don't know
it might be
but the trend is no socks because they
have no socks in this uh in this video
neither one of them have socks on so I
don't I don't know where the right wing
is at on this but they were really
pissed off that Joe Biden didn't have
socks on the other day I mean they were
[__] I mean it was like oh my God he
can't be prison impeach him he doesn't
have socks on
but here's Tucker and Tate in this
interview and neither of them have socks
I don't know exactly how the right wing
feels about that
oh boy
so we're gonna get down uh to this also
we're gonna show Gabe Sanchez's new what
was that today he's not able to join us
today all right I'll break the news to
you early here and Gabe Sanchez is not
able to join us today but we are going
to show his what was it so I'll give you
I'll give you your Gabe fix today so
that way you do get to see him but it
just it just won't be live right
well Brenda says he's not in jail he's
under house arrest yeah well he got
charged with more sex trafficking
charges which is even worse for him
uh based on new evidence that they
collected apparently so he listen he's
charged with sex trafficking rather he's
in a jail cell or he's on house arrest
he's under custody
for sex trafficking
in Romania
what do you what do you want from me
I mean I don't make up the rules I don't
make up the facts I just get to tell you
what they are
yeah someone says that Joe Biden is a
trendsetter yeah he started a trend well
I think this interview was recorded
before Andrew Tate got arrested and that
am I right am I wrong I don't know I
really don't know the other thing about
Tucker Carlson doing this interview is
they posted on Twitter the funny part is
is that Tucker's numbers on his little
Twitter show whatever the hell it is
have gone down and down and down and
down and down to down that's because no
one wants to listen to Tucker's [__]
they never really did want to listen to
Tucker's [__] the only reason why
they did listen to Tucker's [__] is
because he was on the eight o'clock spot
on Fox News
that's the pure simple fact no one gave
a [__] about what Tucker Carlson did or
didn't say are what he does or doesn't
say they don't give a [__] the only time
they gave a [__] is when he was on the
eight o'clock hour in Fox News and
that's the reason why they [__] fired
him is because he had creative control
over their biggest [__] hour over
their biggest viewership and they wanted
it back they wanted creative control
back over the eight o'clock hour that's
what they wanted
apparently Jesse Waters is going to be
in that spot
oh my God Jesse Waters is like if Bill
O'Reilly Andrew Tate and Tucker Carlson
all [__] and had a baby and that would
be Jesse Waters right so I mean it makes
sense that Jesse would be in the eight
o'clock spot I don't know when that
starts I don't know when Jesse
officially takes over the I think
they're still got the guest over there I
don't know I don't [__] watch Fox
News I don't watch [__] news in
general
cable news that is [__] boneheads so
as Twitter's down today but I got a lot
of Clips I want to show you I also want
to get back to the Roseanne thing do you
remember
um oh what the hell was it uh I don't
know last week or the week before when
Roseanne did an interview with Theo
Vaughn the ovonne's a comedian Roseanne
used to be a comedian
she still thinks she's a comedian uh but
she made she tried to do satire about
how she would deny the Holocaust do you
remember this
um she did an interview and that now
she's gone on Pierce Morgan's show to
try to rectify the situation only
proving that what she said was [__]
vile trash right because here's the
thing if Roseanne Barr truly was doing
comedy and satire uh and denying the
Holocaust on Theo Von show if that's
truly what she was doing that was the
intention and that's what it was that
she wouldn't have to go on Pierce
Morgan's to explain to the world what
satire is listen if you would do good
satire people would would understand
what the satire is right if you would do
good satire if you're doing horrible
satire some people don't don't see the
satire in it they don't
and it just sounds like you're trying to
use satire to dispouse your vile [__]
ideas and in the Piers Morgan interview
she kinda she kind of proves that
because what she does is she talks about
President zielinski and we know
president zielinski is working very hard
to try to be a member of NATO it looks
like in the coming months or maybe a
year maybe two years uh Ukraine is going
to be a member of NATO the President
Biden when he got to The Summit in the
last few days he said Ukraine isn't
ready and it's a really difficult
situation because they're still at war
with Russia because of Article 5 right
and this is the reason why uh the
Ukraine wants to be part of NATO in the
first place is they want to be protected
by article 5.
you attack one you attack all that's the
Article Five in other words if if
someone attacks a NATO Ally all the NATO
allies get involved and that's what
would keep that's what would keep a
Russia from attacking a NATO Ally or are
invading in a NATO allies State like
Ukraine if they were a member of NATO
right so uh now to to President Biden's
uh credit until zelinski's credit
zelinski is trying to prove that they're
ready to be members of NATO and and the
main thing is is that the United States
and the in the NATO allies
can rely on Ukraine to be a formidable
Force when and if someone attacks
another NATO state or their NATO State
meaning meaning they have to have
um some sort of proof that yes they can
fight they can't stand and I think
they've done that in this war against
Russia and the Russia invasion and and
Vladimir Putin absolutely trying to take
over uh their sovereign state and their
Sovereign democracy Now the the problem
with having Ukraine in NATO the problem
with it is that they are not a a a a
very uncorrupt democracy they are very
corrupt but zielinski has done a lot of
things he ran on this platform he's he's
worked so hard
um to get the corruption out of their
government even though they're at War so
it so it is it is walking on thin ice
here right and trying to manage Ukraine
getting into NATO because I I believe
that NATO wants Ukraine in the Allies
want him in uh NATO and zelinski they
want him in
but it is a difficult task to what nato
in when you you hadn't had the proof
before that they could be a NATO Ally
now that they have proven that with
their battles with with Russia and
fighting off Russia and Russia trying to
take their Sovereign territory uh I
believe that Ukraine has proved that
they are committed to their sovereign
state which is a key tenement to be in
NATO now to protect your sovereign state
not just let someone come in and take
over because that's the whole point
right that's the whole [__] point we
don't want countries in our NATO allies
that would just let Russia come in and
take the NATO Ally state that they would
do everything they possibly could to
fight to keep their sovereign state
which I believe Ukraine has done even
though they're not a NATO Ally so the
proof is in the pudding there the
problem is is that the pudding's not
done yet right it's not done yet and the
reason why is because there's still uh
there's still an ongoing hot war in
Ukraine against the invasion of vladim
Putin in Russia now does that seem to be
coming to an end and I actually believe
that the signals
um giving to Ukraine that hey you're
going to be in here in NATO sooner than
later is good indication that they have
good intelligence that Russia will fall
um Putin's after after the pagosian
Insurrection or Mutiny whatever you want
to call it the the coup attempt that was
hap that happened by pregosian a couple
weeks ago has only showed the huge signs
of Putin's weakness uh as Putin is
working hard to try to recover from that
from showing that weakness speaking of
fragile men oh my God this is why they
idolize Putin did you know that oh
they're like oh God damn Trump and Putin
they're the [__] picture perfect of
oppressed fragile men the [__] out of
here Jesus Christ what a bunch of
[__] victims aren't they just God
damn victims yeah someone's pointing out
Norway
um so as as the as the NATO allies stack
against
dictatorships in this in this world
um I think it really
it really gives a good signal to the the
rest of the world that hey we're going
to stand with Western democracy we're
going to stand with liberty and freedom
even if it's not perfect okay because
democracies aren't perfect that's that's
actually kind of the point I don't know
if you know that that it's it's the
point that it's not perfect right
the point is is that we work harder to
make it better
to make it better for us to make it
better for future Generations
um as we as we knock on the door of the
hottest day of the of the recorded on
the planet which I'm sure it'll continue
with global warming climate change
and all these deniers out there
absolutely denying this stuff
it's another huge story that is uh
starting to make its waves
about climate change affecting your
pocketbook apparently Farmers Insurance
the company Farmers Insurance has left
Florida uh several others are leaving
Florida but uh I think Farmers was
neither number four number five in the
State of Florida like no we're not going
to write policies here anymore
[__] you
no we're not gonna do it uh parts of
Florida still battered by the the recent
hurricane
um that Ron DeSantis tried tried to get
his white boots on you know his white uh
his cheerleading his cheerleading books
boots remember those remember those he
put those on he's trying to walk around
in his DeSantis for president vest or
whatever the hell it was
and uh
he failed he failed just like I said he
would he failed he failed the people of
Florida because not only are there
insurance premiums going up by 60 70 80
90 percent some of them are losing their
insurance policies altogether
which is again Jesus Christ another
[__] story
in this fragile male category the main
one being the governor of Florida Ron
DeSantis he's so [__] worried about
wokism oh whoop this and woke that and
[__] those woke insurance companies
that Floridians don't need woke ass
insurance right Jesus [__] Christ
this guy's a [__] idiot
what a [__] idiot Ron listen to me
God damn it listen to me
either either get in the presidential
race like I've been telling you to our
Gobi Governor you [__] idiot one of
the other resign and run
and do that or go be Governor the
[__] people in the State of Florida
need your dumb ass and they don't need
you be worrying about Disney and wokeism
they need you to worry about real
[__] problems that affect their
pocketbook you dumb son of a [__]
I I don't know how more clear to say it
I hope that clears it up for Ron
meatball pudding fingers D scientists
[__] idiot
um but again
this is just more and and again the
state's gonna be in more hot trouble
because this idiot keeps focusing on
[__] that doesn't affect anyone but
himself but himself
just like Trump whining and crying about
prosecution uh as Fanny Willis and the
Georgia the Georgia grand jury there in
Fulton County
and presses Donald Trump now uh I don't
know that we've gotten any kind of
result from the filing that was uh
happened late the other night from the
Trump Camp to delay this trial for the
documents case but it's clear that it's
going to get delayed the Department of
Justice asking for a December trial date
I imagine that they kick this can as
I've been telling you from the very
beginning that they would pass the
election
I don't know if we've got word on that
but again again and again and again we
run into these fragile [__] men Jesus
Christ and then they try to act like
they're the picture of masculinity the
[__] out of here with this nonsense if
Ron DeSantis was any kind of picture of
masculinity get down there and he'd
[__] helped Floridians clean up that
goddamn mess from that hurricane and do
everything he can and his power as the
governor of the state of Florida to make
sure Floridians aren't [__] drowning
not just in hurricanes but drowning in
the goddamn insurance premiums on their
property
because it's not their it's not exactly
their [__] fault and some people are
like oh well Tony they can just pick up
and move you son of a [__] you son of a
[__] listen people can't just [__]
pick up their lives and move to act like
you can just oh well if you can't afford
it [__] property insurance what makes
you can think you can afford to pick up
and move somewhere stop being so goddamn
[__] heartless
okay
We're All in This Together in this
country especially when it comes to
climate change
I don't give a [__] what their views are
I don't care we're all in this together
when it comes to climate change if we
don't do it together we're really [__]
so we don't need Governors running
around the country saying
woke into a microphone when they could
be in their state doing the [__] work
of their constituents and helping the
[__] people of that state
it's ridiculous
and just and to think that he would make
a good president get the [__] out of
here what do you think he's gonna do for
you when some crisis hits in this
country he's gonna go yell and scream to
his little [__] sheep about how woke
the left is when he'll let the country
burn he doesn't give a [__] he doesn't
give a [__] he's a fascist
they don't care about other people than
themselves just like this interview with
Tate and Tucker I mean you know I I know
I know it's like what the [__] is the
interview with Tate and Tucker have to
do it has everything to do with it
because this is the [__] disease that
we have to deal with
this woke mind virus literally that's
what they've got DeSantis Trump Tate
Tucker they can't focus on anything else
but wokism as if it has anything to do
with anything
they're outside their [__] minds
complaining about how hard it is to be a
man get the [__] out of here you you
dumb [__] man
you wouldn't last two [__] seconds as
a woman Tate Tucker DeSantis Trump you
win last two [__] that's why I'm listen
I I am I am [__] happy as a lark that
I'm a white man I don't know that if you
know how much I know that I'm on the top
rung of the ladder and I started there
I see everyone down below me and I'd
love to pull them up that's what I want
I want Equity Inequality For All I don't
I don't want your skin color or your
gender to dictate and give you a leg up
in this Society it's gonna take a long
time to do that I understand that too I
know you can't just snap your [__]
fingers and boom it's changed but we
damn sure can talk about it and we damn
sure can push it in that direction and
that's what they're scared of
that's what they're terrified of they're
like oh my God it's tough enough for me
to be such a scumbag
without people complaining that I'm a
scumbag what's gonna happen well what's
gonna happen when I have to compete with
women
but you're already competing with women
and they're much better than you that's
why I think we should get to a place
where women run this country the whole
[__] thing that's right and all we we
should do a total reversal of what we
were doing 50 years ago 50 years ago men
controlled everything the school boards
the county governments the state
governments the federal government the
whole [__] ball of wax and we should
hand it all over to women every [__]
last bit of it over the next 40 years we
should hand it all over to women and let
them [__] fix this country
it's enough of this [__] men have [__]
this [__] up long enough
it's enough of it
I'm sick of having [__] men [__]
everything up
it's it's tiring it's exhausting when we
have plenty of competent women who know
exactly what to do they women know how
to govern
like a [__] they know how to
govern it's Peru it's true
oh boy we're gonna have a good show
today I don't know exactly what's gonna
happen I'm gonna play Gage what was that
uh for you guys when we come back from
the break we'll play games what was that
and then and then we'll see if Twitter's
up threads is up maybe I'll show you
both show you what the differences are
that way you can guys get a sense of
should I open a threads account or not
and should I follow Tony on threads you
damn right you should you should also
hit subscribe right here on the YouTube
channel don't forget to subscribe
it's 3.99 every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central
you can also watch us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels
sometimes you can watch us on Twitter if
it's up and running at Tony Michaels pod
and you can download every single
episode in the afternoon once I get it
edited and uploaded you can download it
on Apple's Spotify Google
you should be doing that you should
download the auto it helps out the show
Keeps Us in the rankings we want to get
in the top rankings we just need to
I don't know I don't know I haven't
figured out the algorithm over there yet
to be quite honest with you
I've tried I've worked on it but yeah it
happens I want to thank everyone
following us over on Twitch
and watching on Twitch thank you very
much and everyone don't forget don't
forget if you've got your Amazon Prime
account linked to your Twitch account
you'll want to resubscribe
now let's see eight minutes ago we had
salty semester over there on Twitch
re-subscribe for five months in a row
thank you very much salty thank you so
so much
so make sure to go over and re-subscribe
if you haven't and if you have an Amazon
Prime account and you haven't linked it
to a Twitch account do that too here's
what you can go you can go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the tonymichaels.com
it's the fourth link down it's the
fourth button down you just click that
and it gives you specific directions on
how to link your Prime account to your
Twitch account and give us that one free
subscription because it doesn't cost you
any extra money to give us a little
money each month when you have a Prime
account so check that out and don't go
anywhere we're gonna do Gabe Sanchez's
what was that here really soon when we
come back from from the break so don't
go anywhere we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott finder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
and it's a Wednesday July 12th it's
inches can't join us he's doing uh he's
doing a little Excursion and he's gonna
be doing it the rest of the week I'm not
even sure if he can join us for bonehead
of the week I think what I'm gonna try
to do
is find a a a guest co-host for bonehead
of the week
so if you guys have suggestions of who
you'd like to see as a guest co-host
a bonehead of the week on Friday and
give us give it give me a shout and also
I gotta figure out how to do the
graphics
he's he's gonna be out of pocket on
Friday that's that's going to be the
problem
that's that's going to be the problem is
uh is he's gonna be out of pocket he's
just he's not going to have some people
are saying Texas poll Dr Rachel
bittickoffer hey that's a good one
that's a good one Amanda a lot of people
are saying um Texas but I need to get
Rachel back on the show don't I
I need to get Rachel back on your right
I need to get Rachel Jordy from Midas
Dutch I hate you know what I can see if
Jordy could join us the problem is we do
it live so I gotta have someone who has
the time during that that that you know
that that segment
that's the uh the Army Major yeah sure I
could get the Army Major too I might I
might these are see you guys are the
smartest audience in the world
you guys
um you guys are on top of things so
let's see who else who else uh Hal
Sparks I don't know does Hal do a show
during that the sparklers in the chat no
I don't know exactly how it's scheduled
sometimes we overlap but there's some
days that we don't overlap
um for for bonehead Boston Brian would
be great some people have um Wanted
Boston Bryant on the show Michael Cohen
I'm I you know these are great
suggestions
Michael Rappaport
I might be I'll get Michael I don't know
I I don't know Michael all the other
ones that you guys have said I I know
them but I I don't I don't have like a
direct line to Michael Rapaport the
other ones I could get a hold of but uh
you know it says politics girl there you
go
let's see who else do we have here uh bo
you talking about Bo the fifth column I
think is what you're saying Tennessee
Brando I like Tennessee Brando I love
his music
oh my God he's been doing some great
videos here lately but didn't you love
his music we played several songs the
Tennessee Brando uh wrote here on the
Tony Michaels podcast Ben I think you're
saying Ben myzealous there uh for for a
guest co-host maybe I'll put the word
out today and see if I can get someone
to
um and guest host because I was just
going to do it by myself if nothing else
Fred Wellman there's another one we had
Fred on a couple weeks ago
and Fred was fun Fred was great we
should have him on more listen I the
reason why I don't have that many guests
is because
ah just be honest a lot of people don't
like me well that's how it goes you know
what I mean uh I need to get Jess Piper
back on the show too there's another one
I gotta get Jess back on the show I I I
I asked her a couple weeks ago she was
out and about she wasn't able to be on
the show so I said ah we'll do it we'll
do it soon so I and just you know
I get so excited to talk about these
things that I talk about them for two
hours and I ain't got room for guests
that's why that's why I need to move the
three hours really uh some people saying
popoc
I used to have pop on frequently
remember the pope Poppin do I still have
that [__] graphic let's see I do here
it is
there's the pope Pock
Poppin and graphic if if you're OG
you'll remember that if you're OG you
remember that we used to have uh pop on
uh several times and me and him would
yeah we we would sometimes uh agree
sometimes disagree
let's see who else who else do we have
um
I don't know some of these names John
Stewart I'd have John on
yeah I'd bring I probably would I
probably would um have more questions
for John than we would just talk about
the bonehead of the week you know what I
mean I'd probably have a lot of
questions for him that wouldn't even
relate to Bone end of the week if I had
Jon Stewart I mean if you have Jon
Stewart on you got a chance to ask him
some questions that's what you would do
right
and I and it wouldn't all be related to
politics some of it would some of it
would be related to his work uh within
the 911 families I I really am
interested in to know uh when he when he
uh handed The Daily Show over to Trevor
Noah you know I'm really interested in
knowing that so so if I had John on it
probably asking
so we wouldn't get a lot of bonehead
stuff done uh Trey Crowder hey I I
actually have a video that I like to
show you my tree it's great
it's fantastic uh Believe It or Not uh
so maybe we'll get to that today
who else do we have
who else
um yeah everyone's given love to
Tennessee Brando and Bo the fifth column
Cornell West
no I mean I'd have him on the show but
not as a co-host [__] no you know what
maybe we should do that more maybe we
should have uh guest co-host
and had them on some people are someone
said Jack Black see that would be the
problem with Jack Black too is I'd have
I I we wouldn't get anything done
as far as the bonehead
I'm Keith olberman I'd have Keith on I
like Keith
I used to watch Keith way back in the
day I don't listen to his thing now I
know he has it I follow him on social
media and I've dogged him on the show
too when he he's been off you know what
I mean like when he's not uh um
where he needs to be
um Olivia yeah Olivia
uh Brian Tire cut Tyler Cohen okay
uh Glenn Kushner with Justice matters
Sam seder and no probably not
probably not I'm not I'm not a Sam I
have to admit I'm not a [__] I'm not a
[__] Sam fan but you know that's okay
does that that doesn't mean that he's
not
he's doing shitty or whatever
Farren fair and balanced
that'd be great
uh
see you're just you're just talking [__]
Gustav Steve Bannon I would have Steve
Bannon on the show but it would be to
belittle him and berate him and to tear
him down uh to shreds
that's what it would be that Walter
Masterson yeah Walter's a good choice
too
I've done some streams well one maybe
two I don't know I it was a it was a
long time ago over a year ago Walter
wanted me to do a stream with him and I
streamed with him one time on his
channel
I was kind of like a guest on his thing
and it was it was hilarious because he
was playing character he was in
character as a trump supporter and we
actually believe it or not this is
hilarious we talked about Andrew Tate
during that stream and he was working
out some material and then he went and
he did some videos
I think it was just some um pro-life uh
people in New York it's like a pro-life
Rally or some [__] in New York and he
was talking about how um they would
people would join Andrew Tate's Hustler
University
and now it was some great it's some
great content from from Walter you
should go you should go check that out
someone says Gabe yes face I know Gabe
but Gabe can't be here on Friday that's
what I'm saying uh Mark says what about
the liberal redneck you're talking about
Trey Crowder the other the other good
one would would be Corey Ryan for
Forester
that would be a neck you know he's kind
of he's kind of does the redneck thing
uh it just it's just a little different
than Trey but but they they both are on
the same tour
you know
uh let's see who else do we got here so
you guys are making great suggestions
people say they love Glenn Kushner I you
know I like Glenn but there's some
things that Glenn says that I think
Glenn is uh getting his audience a
little
uh his getting his audience's hopes up
is what I think
you know what I mean I don't know if you
feel the same way but I feel that way
is that sometimes he's saying stuff like
on MSNBC and on some of his stuff
Justice matters to please the audience
right that's that's why I don't try to
[__] [__] you I'm like look
there's not gonna be a trial that
happens don't get excited about a trial
happening for the election because it's
not gonna happen as much as I wanted to
as much as you wanted to that would be
great
that's not that's not in the cards and
you shouldn't say it's in the cards
especially when you know it's not in the
cards and I suspect Glenn knows that
he just won't admit it on his media
platforms because he he wants to get the
audience
um in the mindset that Justice matters
and that Trump's going to be held
accountable which he will be he will be
um Frank back to the Hal Sparks I I'll
get a hold of how how about that I'll
get all the AL I'll ask Texas Paul I'll
see if Rachel wants to come in
um and and the first one the first one
to say yay nay or whatever we'll we'll
see if we can get him on as the um
we'll see if we can get him on as the
guest co-host for bonehead of the week I
gotta find someone to do the graphics
I'm ho Edward if you're listening Edward
if you're listening I'm gonna have to
de-emulator you might have to do the
bonehead graphics for me because if you
don't if you don't they're gonna look
[__] second rate with me doing them
they're not gonna look the same they're
just not but uh we'll we'll work to it
you know me I always work through it we
always do this show no matter what even
if Twitter's down or you know
something's going on and or there's
breaking news and we got to go to this
we got to go to that I always manage I
always manage that's that's a live show
that's a live show uh let's see here
someone's someone's saying oh yeah yeah
so Hal is on when I'm on on Friday maybe
we could do uh I don't know I could talk
to Hal and see if we could do like a
duel
uh uh broadcast where he comes in and
then he's on his and he's um you know
what I mean I don't know I don't know if
we can do that or not maybe we can work
out the logistics of that I don't know
we'll see we'll see I'll contact him and
we'll see who uh
uh someone said Ron
Ron uh philipkowski
um yeah I mean you know I could probably
get Ron on
uh maybe Ron it could be
Kim says write your list up see that's
one thing I'm not good at
I'm not good at that kind of stuff like
that's not my personality
to to to have notes and make a list
and work off and I look I look all
robotic and [__] when I've got notes and
[__] speaking of that
so the president United States meets
with the King of England right kind of a
big meeting I don't know two powerful
people in the world meeting with each
other
they're mad that Joe Biden had notes for
his meeting did you catch this they're
like oh he had index cards yeah with
notes on them to make sure that his
meeting touched all the points that he
needed to touch I mean this show is
important right to narrative and
messaging but I kind of got it all in my
head right when you're doing like world
leader meetings I would say you'd want
to have some [__] notes I I don't
know maybe it's just me maybe uh you
probably wouldn't want to do it the way
that I do the show ah you know you know
what I mean
see what else do we
Mighty librariances are mad about
everything they are aren't they like
like just I mean when I show you this
tape video this Tate Tucker interview
thing whatever the [__] it is where
they're whining and crying about being
men I'm not [__] you they're oh it's
so hard to be a man these days
eat with women
or just imagine just imagine if we
didn't have to compete with women then
then we could put the boot on the back
of their heads and then we would be a
leg up even though we're 10 legs up from
anybody Jesus Christ they're such
[__] babies
there's such whiny [__] [__] Jesus
Christ
um
it is no sign of a man to whine and
complain that you're a man right
like that isn't masculinity at all not
even close and look just because you
lift weights and [__] like that little
[__] on Twitter there just because you
lift weights and [__] doesn't mean
you're a man either none of that [__]
mate that you think makes you a man
makes you a man stop listening to dumb
people
stop listening to dumb people then then
you can you can start to brag about your
manhood okay when you're protecting
other people when you're protecting
other people's families when you're
actually protecting children or you're
actually protecting Women's Health Care
when you're actually advocating to
protect marginalized groups in this
country that's a sign of manhood that's
a sign of strength when you're not
protecting your own [__] interest
protecting your own interest is not a
sign of strength it's a sign of weakness
you dumb [__] and by the way the
amount of your bank account the amount
of your bank account
the amount of your bank account
doesn't dictate your manhood it doesn't
that that's called a capitalist not a
man but you're right money librarian
they're pissed off about everything is
because the one thing they're pissed off
about is Joe Biden not wearing socks
neither of these [__] in this
interview about how manly manliness in
the man's man's man is the man's man man
and man is it hard to be a man man
neither one of them are [__] wearing
socks
neither one of them
you guys want to watch this uh let's go
watch this uh what was that bye by Gabe
let's see if I can get it up here
and then we'll then we'll come back
around to the uh we'll come back around
to the the the Tate Tucker interview
I'll show you that
um after we watched the what was that I
want to watch the what was that first
okay are you guys ready are you guys are
ready
you guys ready to watch see see Gabe's
not on today
but he has his new what was that about
Marjorie Taylor green
and
that makes it to where he's on today
I mean just play pre-recorded by [__]
here's Gabe Sanchez in the new what was
that welcome to what was that I'm Gabe
Sanchez our beloved representative
Martin Taylor green has once again made
headlines but this time it's not for her
outlandish conspiracy theories or her
bigoted taste in legislation it's
because she was expelled expelled yes
that is correct Marjorie Taylor green
the queen of conspiracy theories the
Mistress of misinformation the wild
child with a tinfoil hat has been ousted
from the freedom caucus that's what baby
you're out here but before we jump into
that make sure to like this video
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already and ring that notification Bell
so you never miss another what was that
episode or a comedic sketch for me now
for those of you who don't know the
house Freedom caucus is a group of ultra
conservative lawmakers who love to
remind everyone just how free they are
as long as you agree with their
particular brand of Freedom that is so
when it comes to Margaret Taylor Green's
expulsion what was the straw that
finally broke the camel's back was it
her history of harassing school shooting
survivors or when she made numerous
transphobic homophobic and racist
comments or was it when she claimed that
the Democratic party was a hotbed of
pedophilian Satanism but when she said
that please
[Music]
actually it was none of those things it
was a recent fight in the house floor
with Lauren bobert where she called
and then not only doubled down
tripled down on it in interviews [__]
[__] [__] [__] according to sources
Lauren bobert actually defended Margaret
Taylor Green's freedom of speech during
the party's internal vote however
because bobert wouldn't share how she
ultimately voted something tells me that
she would happily stab Green in the back
but let's just take a moment to
appreciate the irony here the freedom
caucus a group known for its far-right
views thought that Marjorie Taylor green
was too extreme in her conduct on the
house floor that's like the Kool-Aid man
telling you to take it easy on the sugar
apparently the way that green referred
to bobert was not the way that they
expect their caucus members to refer to
other fellow caucus members so that's
not okay but this is Joe Biden you're
not a president you're a piece of [__] I
mean come on Republicans especially ones
from this caucus denigrate their
colleagues almost daily especially
Lauren bobert I was getting into an
elevator with one of my staffers and he
and I are we're leaving the Capitol
we're going back to my office and we get
in the elevator and I see a capitol
police officer running currently to the
elevator I see fret all over his face
and he's reaching and I'm like the
door's shutting like I can't I can't
open it what's happening
I look to my left and there she is
Omar I said well she doesn't have a
backpack we should be fine
you're going to tell me that this or any
of the other numerous bigoted comments
and jokes that bobert has made while
she's been a representative we're not
worthy of expulsion give me a break also
the fact that they expelled green but
are happy to keep George Anthony guitar
Santos who has been indicted on 13
felony counts tells you everything you
need to know about who they are but what
do you expect they're happy to support
Trump despite the fact that he's been
indicted in two separate cases for a
total of 71 felony charges with more
incoming it just shows you how the
Republican party is nothing but a bunch
of Hypocrites and we're just looking for
an excuse to kick her out because a she
was not mad enough and B she was loyal
to kef McCarthy and those things are
what ultimately cost her spot on the
party's bench anyway after green was
expelled she released the statement in
Congress I served Northwest Georgia
first and served no group in Washington
my America First credentials Guided by
my Christian faith are forged steel
seared into my character and will never
change I fight every single day in the
halls of Congress against the hate
America Democrats who are trying to
destroy this country I will work with
anyone who wants to secure our border
protect our children inside the womb and
after they are born and the forever
Foreign Wars and do the work to save
this country the GOP has less than two
years to show America what a strong
unified republican-led Congress will do
when President Trump wins the White
House in 2024. this is my focus nothing
else I love how she said I will fight
every single day in the halls of
Congress against the hate America
Democrats who are trying to destroy this
country but then immediately follows it
up with I will work with anyone Marjorie
Taylor green never makes any sense and
has always been able to constantly
contradict herself it's actually quite
impressive if you think about it but now
the decision to kick green out is
drawing criticism of Perry and the
caucus as a whole according to a senior
Republican aide if I'm Scott Perry this
is the last thing I want making headline
leading into three weeks of session
before the August recess all of the
continuous drama surrounding hfc has put
their members at odd of getting any
agenda items passed it has to be tiring
for leadership so while the division
within the Republican Party grows larger
the Democratic party continues to Stand
United in passing legislation to
actually help the American people you
all see projects for delivery
communities all across America
look implementing this legislation also
has another transformative impact
all those members of Congress who voted
against it suddenly realized how great
it is
and they're bragging about it as my
mother was saying God love them
I want to thank Senator grant for voting
for the five cars infrastructure
and the chips of the science side I wish
he had voted for the rest
every Republican member of the Congress
voted against the inflation reduction
act everyone
every Republican member of the House
on this state voted to repeal the clean
energy provisions of the inflation
reduction Act
that that attached attracted all these
jobs
you know and then after that effort
failed the public and study committee
which includes over three quarters of
the House Republicans just released the
plan
to go out trying to repeal it all again
I hadn't stopped them though from
claiming credit
now the billions of dollars and
thousands of jobs are coming to the
United States and maybe now with all her
new free time Margaret Taylor green can
do just that focus on solving Americans
issues I'm sorry are you saying that
after all of this happened she's been
busy playing miniature golf
[Music]
and now she's doubling down again on
what she called bobert Margaret Taylor
green corrected the Daily Mail tweet by
uncensoring little [__] and then
tagging Community notes God she is such
a child okay you know what fine if Marge
won't do her job she can at least do us
the favor of figuring out who is spying
and her using her TV you know the one
that she tweeted about last night in my
DC residence the television turned on by
itself and the screen showed someone's
laptop trying to connect to the TV just
for the record I'm very happy I'm also
very healthy and eat well and exercise a
lot I don't smoke and never have I don't
take any medications I'm not vaccinated
so I'm not concerned about blood clots
heart conditions Strokes or anything
else nor do I have anything to hide I
just love my country and the people and
know how much they've been screwed over
by the corrupt people in our government
and I'm not willing to be quiet about it
or willing to go along with it well that
was TMI and definitely not bizarre at
all though I do love how Marge boasts
about being unvaccinated even though she
owns stock in three yes three major
vaccine May but seriously I really hope
she finds out who was in her TV though
it would be pretty funny if Lauren bober
was the one with her this whole time
[Music]
foreign
[__]
so as we bidded you to Marjorie Taylor
Green's Freedom caucus membership let's
hope this serves as a cautionary tale a
tale that reminds us to choose our
elected officials wisely or else we'll
just continue to live in this Bizarro
world where immature drama queens write
our laws thanks so much for watching
this episode of what was that if you
want to see more videos like this make
sure to subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications and like this video and of
course if you want even more content
like this you can always follow me on
Instagram at I am Gabe Sanchez and
before you go if you want to support me
as an independent Creator and my other
content make sure to join my community
at patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
there you go folks there you go what was
that with Gabe Sanchez he couldn't join
us today so I figured
I'll let you get your Gabe fix so go do
that go go follow Gabe on YouTube just
go to just go to I am Gabe sanchez.com
all the links are there go to his link
tree go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
go to what was that show.com here let me
bring that graphic up just go to what
was that show.com that'll take you
directly to his patreon where you can
support him in making that content
that's one of the best episodes that
he's had I think so he's getting better
and better at it I mean they were good
before but they're getting better better
so go support Gabe wherever you can
whether you're liking sharing uh
subscribing to his channel make sure
you're watching those what was that
um it's very important he works super
hard on them I don't know if you noticed
but he works super hard
on those episodes okay so I have I have
a couple uh let's see a couple things I
want to show you here on uh speaking uh
should I show that yeah
speaking of bobert
here's Chelsea Handler she had a great
video now Twitter's working right now by
the way
so but here is here's Chelsea Handler's
little video so Gabe's on Marjorie
Taylor green here's Chelsea handlers on
Lauren Bowers let's listen I left a
prescription at Pharmacy once I went to
get um birth control the the price was
very very high I said wow is this a
three six month prescription no ma'am
this is one month and I said it's
cheaper to have a kid and I left it
there and now I have my third son Caden
bobert um and so I'm actually it was it
was turned out to be a really great
thing grapefruit ew not the son who had
to call the cops and her husband listen
it's really nice that you like your
child I guess birth control pills can
cost between 20 and 50 for each pack so
let's say it's fifty dollars that's ten
thousand eight hundred dollars after 18
years but the USDA estimates that
parents can expect to pay between
fifteen thousand and seventeen thousand
a year raising a child so that's about
three hundred thousand to raise a kid to
the age of 18. and that's not even
including if you're Lauren bobert how
many guns you have to buy for each of
them now Lauren is getting divorced if
she has to pay child support she's going
to find out exactly how expensive kids
are their divorce comes two decades
after the couple first met while Lauren
was working at Mickey D's at the age of
16 and are soon to be ex-husband was 22.
sounds like someone was ordering a Happy
Meal I can't spend too much time talking
about this because I want to try out the
new water slide I had installed at my
new house that I bought with all of the
disposable income I have from taking
birth control and never having kids bye
Lauren I heard you have a new boyfriend
so maybe try condoms or anal
oh Chelsea Handler putting a putting me
in the correct position to go zero days
without talking about porn oh Jesus
Christ that's another thing you can do
if you don't wanna if you want to have
an orgasm and not have babies and you
can use condoms anal and just jerk off
that's cool you know you can do that
Chelsea oh man I'm glad I watched that
video by her the other day I'm glad I
showed it to you maybe she'll knock me
on it maybe she won't okay so let's go
to
um oh I you know what I'm gonna show you
some videos of this hearing with
director Ray
um here in just a bit and I'm gonna go
to threads to show it to you on ason's
page Athens got some clits uh Eric
swallow and some others questioning uh
the FBI director who was appointed by
Trump but um Kevin McCarthy responded
yesterday because they're Hunter Biden
Joe Biden thing is all falling apart I
don't know if you know this their
whistleblower that they talked about
their fake ass whistleblower that they
talked about has been charged with uh
being a Chinese spy and an illegal arms
dealer oh and an Iranian spy too that
that they do oh and lying to the federal
authorities huh it's almost like it's
almost like this guy has a history of
lying to the feds about [__] that isn't
true hmm and this is their whistleblower
but here yesterday is Kevin McCarthy
trying to pick up the pieces of their
fallen Narrative of Hunter and Joe
bidener corrupting it's all the Deep
State and we need to we need to arrest
him and send them get more but we we
can't we can't uh arrest our political
opponents we can't try our political
opponents but we should try our
political I don't know it doesn't make
sense let's see if he can make sense
that he probably won't
who who some are saying something
different that have no philosophy
llis one way or another you're concerned
about equal justice coming before the
Ways and Means Committee and it's
interesting now
even that it wasn't just said in the
meaning they took notes and they sent it
back it was so questionable when he said
that he couldn't become a special
prosecutor that he got asked the
question back because the individual
knew how important
okay remember yesterday when I was
talking about they try to make these
things so kind yeah I know the volume
I'm trying to adjust the volume for
whatever reason it's not doing it
it's not doing it I I wish I could get
the volume better on this clip oh yeah
everyone's saying too quiet I know I was
trying to get the volume up
but basically Kevin McCarthy is making
up this big long story about why the
prosecutor who Who was appointed by
Trump to prosecute Hunter Biden and Joe
Biden in Delaware to put them in prison
you know you know like uh make a
political prosecution on your political
opponents what the Republicans are
saying is happening now with Trump
they were investigating crimes that
didn't exist
the best they could find was Hunter
Biden Hunter Biden made a few mistake on
his tax returns Hunter Biden paid the
taxes that he owed because of the
[__] mistakes that he made on his tax
returns they still charged him and he
still pled guilty to the misdemeanors
and a felony gun charge which anyone out
there that is a two-way bro and you're
not [__] infuriated by the gun charge
that Hunter Biden pled to just that it
exists just that it exists as an
infringement to your second amendment
rights you two a Bros but then
everything go on and on and on and on
and make excuses and tell this Grand
story about why the prosecutor Who was
appointed by Trump to prosecute Hunter
Biden to make sure that Joe Biden didn't
win
why that is now part of the deep State
and they tell this big long stupid ass
story that is not in any way factual
it's all [__] but again it's to make
the dumb feel smart that's why they do
these complicated stories that's why
they're doing these complicated stories
around Hunter Biden and how Joe Biden's
connected and how it's all part of China
China and all this [__] and the reason
why is because they need their
supporters the dumb ones to sound smart
you'll see it you see it in your comment
threads if you're on social media and
you say anything about anything and
they're like yeah but what about Hunter
Biden and barisma and then this person
and that person this whistleblower and
that yeah that's all complicated [__] so
that that way the dumb feel smart so
they'll keep spreading it around but
here is let's go let me see if I can
find
um
[Music]
oh yes here it is this is the um let's
see if we can play this on threads I I
know uh I haven't I haven't really
screen shared a video on Bridget
so this is uh this is the first
opportunity that we have here we go okay
so here is here's threads now you can
only view threads on a web browser and I
don't even know if I'm gonna be able to
view this very well
there we go okay so this is aces tweet
uh now this is this morning
um where director Ray and and Jim Jordan
are uh are uh he's being questioned by
Jim Jordan let's what the see what I
mean I I don't know if this is gonna
work or not quite Rich to me that you're
hearing all these allegations from
somebody who won't even respond to a
lawful subpoena but I want to talk more
about your work instructions are to be
as sparing as possible in the redactions
that we provide gentleman from
California is recognized director I
think it's quite Rich that the guy that
has accused you of lawlessness and
weaponization is 400 Days into violation
of his own Congressional subpoena over
January 6. quite Rich to me that you're
hearing all these allegations from
somebody who won't even respond to a
lawful subpoena
so there's there's Eric swallow here's
another uh clip of Eric swalwell
um handing it to the Jesus this this
this threads thing listen Zach all right
I can't do it anymore I can't do it
anymore we're gonna have to go back to
Twitter Zuck listen you got to get your
[__] together on the uh
you got to get your [__] together
on getting threads to be
to be easy on a web browser it's just
something you're gonna have to do quick
fast in a hurry you can't waste no more
time all right let's see let me go to
let me go to acen's um
his Twitter feed I'm sure he's posting
he's on Twitter I want to show you these
clips from this uh uh from this here we
go okay so here is here is an extended
here's the extended swallow clip that I
was just trying to show you here it is
uh on Twitter it's on asen's account
it's the same clip it's just on a
different social media and again Zuck
get your [__] together over there on
threads and I'll just show everything
from threads not from Twitter just do
that chairman I've counted in this
hearing and we're only about
an hour and a half in the use of the
word laptop about 20 times in fact in
the Chairman's opening statement he said
that he's upset that he believes the FBI
prevented more Americans from learning
about a private Citizen's laptop
that is bananas to me
you all are bringing up fisa every
single question
you're
essentially saying to the American
people that you're guardians of personal
security and privacy
but the 2020 election
was determined because the FBI note
because the FBI didn't let more
Americans
see a private citizens non-consensual
nudes is that what we're saying here
that you lost the election not because
of your ideas but because of private
Citizen's laptop do you want an answer
out there
that's bananas like you should be a
party of ideas not a party of
non-consensual nudes to help you win an
election
that is what the objection is here today
we should be talking about the mass
shootings that occurred over the last 10
days this hearing has turned into
absolute chaos and I yield back there
you go there's the clip from acen and
Eric swallow dunking uh Jim Jordan in
the trash you notice two different
things there that Eric swalwell does
number one he points out the fact that
that's all this is about is this idea
that they were somehow gonna lock up
Hunter Biden because of his laptop right
which doesn't exist the laptop is all
[__] every last [__] bit of it is
[__] and and again he brings up the
point that you guys lifted his nudes put
it with a bunch of other [__] that has
nothing to do with anything but what you
[__] want to talk about all you
want to do is talk about Hunter Biden's
hog
his huge ass hog and the fake ass [__]
that you put on what you call the heart
the laptop which doesn't exist
and you're saying you're saying that it
is it is illegal
to put a fisa warrant on a [__]
private citizen but what you guys want
to do is drag a private citizen through
through public scrutiny about [__]
having Nudes on a laptop
get your [__] [__] together is what
swalwell's saying
get your [__] [__] together
um someone said Yup his hog is huge
sheep we are going zero days without
talking about porn now this isn't like
professional porn this is just amateur
porn then Hunter Biden was taking of
himself and him and hookers right like
you know what I
said listen
I know a lot of people out there think
that it is a horrible thing that Hunter
Biden paid for hookers I actually don't
see that as that horrible of a thing
it's not that hard look sex work is work
let's not demonize sex workers for
crying out loud it's the oldest [__]
profession on the face of the Earth okay
and and the reason why is because it's
women women are are strong and they had
the first profession fellas they had the
first profession and the oldest
profession so ease up on the whole
you're a man thing okay ease up on that
we're gonna get to the Andrew Tate thing
I promise
I can't wait for you to hear him [__]
whine about being a dude oh my God it's
it's hilarious anyways anyways don't
denigrate sex workers okay don't do that
I don't give a [__] who you are what if
if if it's consensual and they're of age
sex work is work [__] and you shouldn't
be denigrating these people honestly we
should be keeping sex workers safe is
what we should that's what we should be
working on in society to do is to
legitimize legitimize the sex work
no no that know that everyone in the
country
at some point in their lives has
probably probably used that sex work as
a way to you know entertain themselves
rather it be prostitution whether it be
porn
so stop denigrating sex workers you
[__] and when you do that when
you do that [__] you put sex workers
rather they're in porn are there or or
their or their prostitute you you put
them in danger is what you do
that's one of the things I did not like
what Democrats did with with the sex
trafficking bill is they made they made
legitimate sex worker workers unsafe
because legitimate sex work is work so
stop with that nonsense and the idea
that somehow that's the most egregious
thing that Hunter Biden did get the [__]
out of here man are you kidding me the
worst thing that he did was have some
prostitutes what that's the case then
Donald Trump shouldn't be anywhere near
the presidency you [__] buffoons
the [__] out of here with that [__]
that that's the most egregious thing
that Hunter Biden's ever done is pay for
consensual sex [__] out of here and and
post it and then do drugs together oh my
God oh my it's 2023 folks it's 20 23
people do drugs people have sex people
pay for drugs people pay for sex it's a
thing that a lot of people do so quit
quit quick and acting like that's
ridiculous now when you're talking about
addiction and Hunter Biden not having
his life together because he's addicted
to those things now we can have a
discussion about something but hunter
Biden is a private [__] citizen so
who gives a [__] when it comes to
Congress why is Congress so interested
in Hunter Biden's huge ass hog why why
Jim Jordan are you focused on his dick
that's what Eric swallow wants to know
Jim Jordan's like can I answer can I
answer Eric swallow was like well you
will tell a lie what you should say is
you love looking at pictures of Hunter
Biden's dick
I think that's what I think that's what
he does okay let's watch um
let's see what this uh Ken Buck here
says uh to Ray I I don't know what this
clip is as part of the hearing so let's
go to it I'm sure he says something
about the you know
laptops or something maybe no socks
maybe he asked director Ray if he wears
socks it seems to be important you
started out as a an ausa and I'm getting
this information from Wikipedia The
Great font of knowledge in the digital
age so what did the [__] did he just say
did he I I have not watched this
I have not watched this are you [__]
kidding me
did he just did he just say let me see
if I can turn this [__] thing up a
bit Jesus Christ are you kidding me
let's see if I can turn this up a bit
let's listen to this at ausa and I'm
getting this information from Wikipedia
The Great yep he did say he did he just
said
he just said he got this [__] from
Wikipedia are you [__] okay listen
I've told you this before and I'll say
it over and over again one reason why
Republicans look like such dumb bucks in
these committee hearings is because they
don't have actual serious staff
okay
so on Capitol Hill or in any any state
capital for that matter any state
capital or on Capitol in DC
there are professional staffers okay
that is what they do as a career
they went to school a lot of them get
their law degrees a lot of them get
their Poli SCI degrees
political science degrees it depends on
what kind of staffer they want to be do
they want to be part of the political
staff do they want to be part of the
Congressional staff do they want to be
part of writing bills I mean all these
things matter and a lot of them go to
law school to go write bills on Capitol
Hill or in state houses for politicians
because politicians can't do it all now
you also had the professional staff that
prepare
that prepare Congress people rather they
are a congressman a congresswoman a
senator a state senator state
representative a governor for crying out
loud and these people in these staffs
will be administrative right and also
informative meaning that they're they're
trying to brief they're trying to brief
these people who are going to speak in
front of microphones about what the hell
is going to happen and who's going to be
in front of them and this [__]
idiot's like look I don't have enough
staff they're [__] incompetent and
they're stupid as [__] so what I had to
do what I had to do was go look you up
on Wikipedia are you [__] kidding me
what the [__] what the [__] no no I'm
telling you I'm telling the reason why
Lauren bobert
appears to be dumb as dog [__]
other than she is dumb as dog [__]
but she she really steps in a lot of
[__] garbage in these committee
hearings is because she doesn't have a
staff that prepares her
if you had good staff the staff is going
to formulate questions so you don't step
in it so you don't look like a dumbass
Eric swalwell we just noticed he's
really good at this he's really good at
what he does but one of the reasons why
Eric swalwell is so good at what he does
is because he has a good staff
he has a really good stamp Jamie Raskin
probably has one of the best staffs on
Capitol here Hill
that's why Democrats appear to be more
serious
is because they have more serious staff
and the reason why
this is is because people who want to be
career staffers don't always follow
their ideology to be a staffer there are
some people who are quote conservatives
who are on Democratic staffs
because that's their job that's their
job even though the [__] that they write
the questions that they write the stuff
that the politician says of whose staff
they're on they don't exactly believe
everything that they say it's because
it's their job they're paid to do what
they're supposed to be doing it's a job
it's a career
they make a living their entire lives of
this
and there are serious [__] staffers
on Capitol Hill and the majority of them
are on the Democrats
staffs
and it shows just like here with Ken
Buck let's keep going a lot of knowledge
in the digital age so I'm assuming that
it's true but you started out as an ausa
you uh were nominated by Republican
President Bush for the position of
Assistant Attorney General in the
Criminal Division at the Department of
Justice and you were confirmed by a
Republican Senate if I uh am correct in
that
uh yes by uh unanimous Voice vote and
and you were then nominated by
Republican president Donald Trump uh to
be the FBI director and again confirmed
by the Republican Senate uh uh for that
position uh yes I think there were only
five votes against me and they were all
uh from Democrats
um according to Wikipedia you're still a
registered Republican and I hope you
don't change your party affiliation
after this hearing is over
um but I want to thank you
um I want to thank you okay so Ken Buck
is making points here about how uh Ray
was appointed by Trump this is so
[__] stupid that they even have to do
this [__] it is so dumb that Ken Buck
has to sit here in this hearing and give
you [__] facts that everyone should
know they have to put this on the
[__] the public record in front of
the entire country because the
Republicans his party his party can buck
are a bunch of [__] idiots and why to
the Sheep to make them dumber than dog
[__]
that's really [__] crazy
let's see is there anything about uh
cocaine
I don't I don't know they probably ask
questions about cocaine don't you think
come on I I come on come on come on come
on oh oh here here's a good one
um it looks like um
representative Dean is going to ask
about a few things that might be
relevant uh to Mar-A-Lago let's listen a
ballroom a bathroom a bedroom
but those appropriate places to store
classified confidential information
well again I don't want to be commenting
on the pending case but I will say that
there are specific rules about where to
store classified information and that
those need to be stored in a skiff a
secure compartmentalized information
facility and in my experience ballrooms
bathrooms and bedrooms are not Skiffs
oh
it's part of the case like that's the
whole point of it
the whole point of it is that new the
presidential records act it has to do
with the Espionage Act see that's why
they're charging in with the Espionage
Act they're not charging him because he
broke the law against the presidential
records act that's the that's the thing
so and that's why Donald Trump keeps
yelling and screaming about the
presidential records Act is because he
knows that that's the dumbest defense
ever so that's why he's picking it
because
he's an idiot
um okay
let's go and see if I can find some more
clips of this uh I'm interested in this
um let's see did Aaron oh oh here's
here is Aaron rupar uh looks like this
is a meeting or this is Ted Lou in the
same in the same hearing let's listen
Trump advisor Roger Stone was convicted
in a federal court correct
that's my recollection
Trump donor Elliot Brady was convicted
in a federal court correct
also my recollection
the Attorney General at the time for
those two convictions was Bill Barr
which president nominated Bill Barr for
attorney general uh president Trump
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen was
convicted on two separate occasions in a
federal court correct
I believe that's correct the Attorney
General at a time for Cohen's second
conviction was Matthew Whitaker which
president appointed Matthew Whitaker as
acting Attorney General
uh president Trump
's foreign campaign chairman Paul
manafort was convicted in a federal
court correct
yes Trump's former deputy campaign
manager Mr Gates was convicted in a
federal court correct that's my
recollection Trump's campaign foreign
policy adviser George Papadopoulos was
convicted under federal court correct
uh yes I think yeah he pled guilty yes
the Attorney General at the time of
those three cases was Jeff sessions
which president nominated Jeff sessions
for attorney general president Trump
you were their FBI director for all of
those cases at the time which president
nominated you president Trump okay what
these facts show is we don't have a
two-tiered system of justice we have one
Department of Justice that goes after
criminals regardless of party ideology
all of these folks were convicted under
the administrations of three separate
Republican Attorneys General
it is not the fault of the FBI that
Donald Trump surrounded himself with
criminals Donald Trump brought that upon
himself
thank you to the FBI for exposing the
Cesspool of Corruption of these Trump
Associates okay there's Ted Lou just you
know again doing the whole
hey you're you you were you were
appointed right this person was
appointed right yeah the who appointed
this person and and Melissa says I love
all the the fact checking here's the
problem with all of this
is that they're they're not going to
listen to it
right and it's good that the Democrats
and some of the Republicans are putting
on record over and over and over and
over and over again
trying to rebut some of the crazies in
the [__] room who are in who on this
committee who are asking director Ray
outlandish stupid questions that you
wouldn't ask when you know the simple
facts that Ted Lou just laid out
but they're gonna ask them and the
reason why is because they need the
highlights on oam they need highlights
and Newsmax they need they need people
like Benny Johnson Seb Gorka they need
people like these right-wing fascists to
spread this [__] all over the [__]
internet
without the facts without the facts
cause folks
I'm telling you and I keep saying this
over and over and over again the thing
that you have to do is engage in your
democracy
you have to you have to engage
you can't just and and this watching
this show is part of it that's one way
you can commenting talking to people
here in the chat but in real life is
more important than anything
it's more important in real life than
ever before
and the reason why is because people
have been given permission by social
media to develop their own [__]
narrative their own bubble
and because again I say this all the
time we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life
but the problem is before the internet
before social media was so hard for
someone to gain their own narrative to
gain their own sense of Truth
right now more than ever you can use
your own bias you can use the internet
to develop a story and sometimes it
feels like these people are watching
television shows way too much I was
watching uh with my wife watches a
Netflix series called manifest I'm not
that into it at all really and I haven't
watched it from front to back but I was
watching an episode with her the other
day and I was like holy God damn no
wonder these cute honors believe this
[__] they watch shows like this or like
this sounds like like what I'm going
through it sounds like what I'm going
through and this is could be real and
then they get all confused of what you
know entertainment is and what reality
is
but this is all entertainment to them
they they don't give a [__] to know the
fact that Rey was appointed by Trump
they don't give a [__] to know that
manafort and Gates and Cohen were all
all [__] taken down by Trump
appointed attorneys they don't give a
[__] that bill Barr was appointed by
Donald Trump they don't care when it
when it interferes with their bias and
it interferes with their narrative they
discount it they discount it ah it's not
a [__] billboard he's a rhino ah the
hell with the people Trump appointed
they're part of the deep State they
discount it immediately
and the reason why is because it doesn't
fit their little narrative
so it doesn't matter about the facts and
this way you can't debate these
[__] you can't debate these
[__]
a debate with another person you have to
agree on a certain set of facts
and if you can't agree on those facts
like Barr is a fascist and that's why
Trump appointed him was to protect King
fascist Trump from being prosecuted and
from getting his ass impeached
then you can't start a debate with them
you can't debate them but they're like
oh no bill Barr's the leftist [__] he's
part of the deep State like get the [__]
out of here
even if Bill Barr wanted to be a leftist
we wouldn't let him be he's not welcome
[__] you [__] off Bill Barr you're not
welcome in our crowd you're just not
you're not pro-democracy you never have
been in your entire life you're just not
you don't like democracy Bill Bard does
not like democracy he only likes what
democracy can deliver him personally him
personally he doesn't give a [__] about
the idea of democracy
okay let's see uh let's go to oh we've
watched that one
just so interested in this uh hearing if
we've got some other Clips let me see if
Aaron has some more Clips on his page
the problem is Twitter is
and Twitter is uh not not functioning uh
completely in this morning I don't think
at it that day let's see if oh here's a
thread he's got a thread going here
let's see if I can find one uh here's um
Nadler
um Jerry Nadler let's see what he has to
say here in this clip
even if you believe as chairman Jordan
claims that President Trump has
committed no crime surely we can agree
that it is dangerous and profoundly
responsible to have taken these
documents from the White House
and left them unsecured in Mar-A-Lago
again don't take just my word for it
Trump's Secretary of Defense Mark esper
said that the former president's
handling of this information could U.S
service members lives in the National
Security at risk
foreign
and Trump's hand-picked attorney general
Bill Barr with whom I agree on very
little hit the nail on the head when he
described the former president's legal
troubles as quote entirely of his own
making he had no right to those
documents the Government tried for over
a year quietly and with respect to get
them back and he jerked them around when
he faces subpoena he didn't raise any
legal arguments engage in the course of
deceitful condom there was a clear crime
crime if those allegations are true
close quote
the former president could have at any
time for months simply returned the
documents and avoided prosecution
that House Republicans did not want to
talk about any of that they seem
incapable of assigning any agency or
responsibility to Donald Trump for
problems that are trumps and trumps
alone
again Jerry Nadler here banging on the
Trump drum which they should over and
over and over again uh because no one
else is going to do it the only one
doing it on the Republican party at this
point is Chris Christie and he's not
doing that good of a job other than
trying to present the reality that
Donald Trump's gonna go to prison
because he committed crimes that's the
only thing that he's doing but he
doesn't really Chris Christie doesn't
point out the danger of why those crimes
matter like why those crimes are against
America and why it's dangerous he
doesn't do a very good job of that he's
just attacking Trump uh to attack Trump
that that that's that's Chris Christie
Now Jerry Nadler here does a pretty good
job of it but Cynthia is Right Jerry
Nadler
should probably consider retiring you
know what the crazy part is you know I
was talking about the stamp earlier and
how there's professional staff and the
reason why Democrats seem much more
serious than Republicans because they
actually have staff Jerry Nadler is not
very good at this the only reason why
Jerry Nadler is like a ranking member
and a committee chair most the time
anyways because he has seniority because
he's been a congressperson for [__]
forever so they get they gains your
seniority in that in that respect but
the thing is that Jerry nanner is even
better than the Republicans in this and
he's not that good at it and the reason
why the reason why Jerry Nadler appears
to be better at this than Republicans
even though he's still not that great at
it is because he has serious staff
and I know I know you're like why do you
keep bringing that up because folks this
is this is why it is so important to pay
attention to things other than just the
sound bites to engage in your democracy
in a way that you know what the [__]
government is and how it works and that
it is us we are the government It Is Us
in this democracy
in this constitutional representative
democratic
democracy that we have
this Republic as they call it yeah it's
a democratic constitutional republic we
elect people to represent us in our
democracy and make choices for us to do
things for us and what we would do if we
were smart is put serious people in
those seats regardless of party that
they can attract serious staff and do
the work that we require them to do
which is to govern huh in that funny
that funny that you know a lot of people
say that I should run I'm like no I'm a
clown I'm the clown show I'm the circus
you don't want the circus running things
okay the circus should be the circus
right our job is to set narrative our
job is to make sure that our country is
headed in the right direction with with
the way that we use media to reach
people
to spread to spread the national message
and to get people all on the same page
and to make sure that we find common
interest in our governance
that's what it's for that's what my job
is
that's what the clowns show the circus
as it called you shouldn't have clowns
in the circus as part of your [__]
elected government like bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green and Matt gatz and
Ted Cruz and Josh Hawley their [__]
clowns
they should go be clowns
not part of the government
saying
Robbie says I love Tony but he's not
Congressman material no they
oh man what's that movie with Eddie
Murphy where he he he runs because of
his name
recognition what the hell is that that
was that movie it's from like the 1980s
where he becomes a member of Congress
he's not a serious prayer he becomes
more of a serious person in Congress uh
it's a great movie it's been a long time
since I've seen it I can't think of the
name of it right off the top of my head
but yeah I'm telling you man
I'm telling you this is not you
shouldn't get the circus running the
show because when you have clowns in
Congress they have clown staffs like
like you the reason why George Santos uh
number one people [__] hate his guts
because he's a liar but he's a
republican they're all liars
they're like oh George Santos lies about
his work and his education and his
background all Republicans do that
Josh Holly doesn't live in Missouri okay
Josh Hawley does not live in Missouri
when he was the attorney general that
[__] snake had to rent a house
he had to rent a house so he could
pretend to be in the state he wasn't
even living in the state when he became
the Attorney General of Missouri
he wasn't even living in the state
he's a he's a [__] fraud they're
frauds they're Republicans they're Liars
they're cheats they're Crooks what do
you want this is their [__]
personality
this is their personalities as who they
are
yeah the other day George Santos says he
he resembles Rosa Parks he compared
himself to Rosa but get the [__] out of
here George Santos you and your you've
been comparing yourself to Rosa Parks
you pile of [__]
the reason why these Republican
politicians are so unpopular throughout
the country and even in their districts
is because they're not serious people
and they don't do the serious work
us out here in the country we want our
kids to be educated we don't want to go
broke because of a [__] medical bill
we want decent [__] wages we want an
economy that isn't going to drown Us in
inflation and price gouging
that's going to take on [__]
corporations and tell them no you cannot
do that by the way inflation is down at
an all-time low the last three years did
you see that holy [__] oh my God it's
almost like what the administration's
doing is working hmm
told you it would work I told you I've
been saying this anyways I digress let's
go back to some clips here let's see if
we can find another clip uh one more
clip of this hearing and then I want to
move on to the Andrew Tate
um Tucker Carlson uh thingamajig
let's see oh I think that's the one that
we Ernest
nope oh here we go here we go this one
should be interesting oh here's two
interesting ones here's Thomas Massey
you got to see this ah here's the
the freeze frame on Thomas Massey here
like in that just in that poetic here
for the freeze frame for Thomas Messi
you know who Thomas Massey is Thomas
Massey is the [__] pile of [__] that
sent out the Christmas card online of
him and his kids
on the couch in front of the Christmas
tree doing what Jesus would want them to
do which is act like Mass Shooters
here's Thomas Massey Thomas Mass shooter
as it were well let's see what he has to
ask the director that was appointed by
Donald Trump 100 days ago is when this
happened and you said you had total
confidence we'd apprehend the subject
we've found video that looks like
somebody a passerby miraculously found
this pipe bomb at the DNC and then
notified the police miraculously I say
because it was it specifically the same
the precise time to cause the maximum
distraction from the events going on at
the Capitol can you show this video that
we have please I'd like to know if the
director has seen this
with a mask on wearing a hat they're
walking in front of the DNC which is out
of the view on the right hand side
you'll see him come into view he goes to
one police car he goes to another police
car he's holding a backpack he's got a
mask on he's talking to the police
and within a minute they start
scrambling you'll see the camera turn
to the pipe bomb the location of the
pipe bomb by the way that's I believe
the Metro Police are not getting out of
their car and that's uh Vice
president-elect's detail in the black
SUV I believe parked about 30 feet from
the pipe bomb eating lunch okay now we
go over to the location of the pipe bomb
the cameras are scrambling
it it appears to me
that that's not a coincidence that the
person with the backpack who walked by
that bench and then went up to the
police
and the detail didn't it didn't do that
accidentally they had a purpose in mind
and then what transpired after that was
the result of information that person
gave to them
if that person
found the pipe bomb would they be a
suspect
well again I don't want to speculate
about specific individuals I will tell
you that we have done thousands of
interviews uh reviewed something like 40
000 video files of which this is uh one
uh says 500 something tips have you
interviewed prices we we have conducted
all logical investigative steps and
interviewed all logical individuals
you need to tell us what you found
because we're finding stuff oh what a
bone-in hey what he found is is that
there might be a member of Congress who
keeps going on social media like I'm not
the pipe bomber
I don't know I don't know they're
talking about the pipe bomb now the
video shown is someone who found the
pipe bomb not the actual pipe bomber you
know but I don't know if Massey is
trying to deflect there and saying that
oh well see the pipe bomber might have
uh alerted the I don't know what the
[__] he's saying they're again it's all
distraction with these [__] idiots
from the real from the real goddamn
problem that's happening in our country
is that these boneheads keep [__]
supporting a goddamn Criminal
that's the problem you keep [__]
capitulating to your cult leader cause
you're a [__] cult speaking of cult
members here's Matt gatz asking I'm sure
this is just going to be [__]
brilliant Matt gants asking the director
Ray questions I will make certain if
it's
but then sitting next to me and every
person he knows and my ability to
forever hold a grudge that you will
regret not following my direction I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father
sounds like a Shakedown doesn't IT
director
oh here it is here it is oh man Matt
Getz is really pissed off about Hunter
Biden and fake text messages oh he's
just he's all been out of shape over
fake test messages that doesn't prove
anything even if they were real which
they're not let's listen to Matt Getz uh
little red or excuse me director's raise
response to Matt Gantz
I'm not going to get into commenting on
that you you seem deeply uncurious about
it don't you almost suspiciously
uncurious are you protecting the bidens
absolutely not the FBI is not as well
you won't answer the question about
whether or not that's a Shakedown and
everybody knows why you won't answer it
because to EV to the millions of people
who will see this they know it is and
your inability to acknowledge that is
deeply revealing about you but let's go
okay so back to what I was saying
earlier about fact checking let me tell
you something they don't give a [__]
about facts because this is the clip
that they want this is the clip that
they want is Matt Gantz talking about
Hunter Biden shaking people down which
is that him talking about fake fake text
messages is no evidence that anyone
shook anyone down the FBI director knows
it but the FBI director can't say it and
the reason why is because there there
was investigations and there's a goddamn
plea deal ongoing he can't just [__]
get out there in front of the world and
tell what the [__] justice department
is doing with their case with Hunter
Biden it's under seal Matt gatz knows it
he knows it he knows it that [__]
[__] box now did I wish that these
people were more prepared for these
[__] clowns in this circus here you
go here's the [__] circus that I'm
telling you about because any serious
person wouldn't ask director Ray about
this in this way because it's not a
serious question you would ask do you
believe that these text messages are
real do you believe that they are real
have you read these text messages has
the FBI received these text messages and
evidence
are are you doing investigation based on
these now Ray would do certain questions
to dance around it but again it's
because these people are not serious and
they do not have serious staff
and they're just look alls they're
looking for is the three second clip for
Fox News oan and Newsmax that's it
this is why we gotta get away from
the circus running the show
it's absolutely ridiculous okay um I
think I'm gonna go to the Andrew Tate uh
Tucker Carlson clip here I'm just gonna
double check here real quick uh oh God
damn I can't skip this one okay this is
Daryl Isa I don't know if you guys know
who Daryl Isa is Daryl Isa you stay if
you remember Way Way Back uh when Barack
Obama was President he was on the overs
he was an oversight chair uh and and
Dara Isa would weaponize the oversight
Committee Against uh Barack Obama and
Eric Holder and others who was the
Attorney General at the time uh to try
to try anything they could to find an
impeachable offense where they can
impeach Biden because that's their
[__] that's their only thing that
they like to do is impeach democratic
presidents for [__] that isn't [__]
relevant and or impeachable but here's
the thing
um here's the thing this is now dare I
said lost his seat and now he's gained
it back because he came back he's not as
high ranking as an official but here he
is asking the FBI about oh my God I
can't even believe this [__] apparently
he's asking the FBI director here the
FBI was had anything to do with
finagling January 6. how many
individuals were either FBI uh employees
or people that the FBI had made contact
with were in the January 6th uh entry of
the capital and surrounding area
so I really need to be careful here
talking about where we have or have not
used confidential human sources was
there one or more was there one or more
individuals that would fit that
description on January 6 that were in or
around the cap I believe there is a uh a
filing in one of the January 6 cases
that can provide a little more
information about this and I'm happy to
see if we can follow back up with you I
just want an answer was there one or
more I mean you would know if there was
at least one individual who worked for
the FBI who entered the capitol on that
day
uh I can't again I just can't speak to
that here but I'm happy to get the court
filing that it's been two years
and you're now you're now come before us
the gentleman asked these questions
makes all kinds of insinuations and you
you nod your head yes and then I asked
you simply was there one or more
and you won't answer that so I'm going
to make the assumption that there was
more than one more than five more than
ten and that you're ducking uh the the
question because you don't want to
answer for the fact that you had at
least one
and somehow missed understanding that
some of the individuals were very
dangerous and that there were others
inciting individuals to enter the
capital after others broke windows so
okay so again Daryl Isa is on to the
truth right they're so [__] close
they run smack right into it right the
reason why the FBI had informants
confidential informants the reason why
they had undercover agents is because
these groups these Trump supporting
groups are terrorist groups
they're they're [__] domestic
terrorist so yeah law enforcement was
infiltrating law enforcement was turning
their own ranks into confidential
informants you [__] boneheads how do
you think this [__] works
Daryl Isa runs straight into it they're
like ah he's like how many of the FBI
was there
but it's not about that it's about
spinning this narrative that the FBI was
all set up somehow the FBI with a few
informants and a few confidential
informants and a few undercover officers
made the whole January 6 Insurrection
happen
just a couple of them maybe five
possibly six created the entire it had
nothing to do with Grandpa standing
standing on stage telling them to go to
the Capitol and to overturn the election
had nothing to do with that or Rudy
Giuliani saying trial by combat or it
didn't have anything to do with the
president United States tweeting out
Mike Pence has betrayed us go hang him
he didn't say that directly but that is
what it led to a chant outside the
capitol hang Mike Pence we've watched
the video of them seeing his tweet in
real time
and to think that that think
that the few confidential informants
that were informing on these domestic
terrorist you [__] they were
informing on these domestic terrorists
and these undercover officers who were
trying to protect our country from these
domestic terrorists
to think that just a handful of them
created that entire situation had
nothing to do with the cult leader
nothing to do with him inciting violence
on the ellipse that day not a goddamn
thing oh and it definitely doesn't have
to do with the members of Congress who
played into the Senators and the
Congress people who played into this
fake elector scheme
Daryl Isa is a lying piece of [__]
trash he knows he's lying here he knows
he's using these kernels of Truth to
spin a big huge lie that the FBI somehow
is responsible for the interaction which
is [__] ridiculous because they can't
they cannot they can't walk away from
the fact that Trump stood on the stage
and told his [__] brainless
supporters to go overturn the election
with the help of The Proud boys and The
Oath Keepers as their [__] ground
troops
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense that somehow a few FBI agents
are confidential informants who are
still confidential informants that's the
other reason why the director can't say
this [__] is because the director can't
give away who are the confidential
informants because they're still
informing
you dumb bastard
Daryl Isa
is Christ
sorry
I'm just [__] yelling and screaming
today whatever you want for me I knew
that I knew this hearing would piss me
off I knew it would now it pissed me off
in a good way folks this is good
politics I don't know if you know this
but this is good Politics the problem is
is that will will people use it
will people use this as the politics
Will They politicize it like I do here
on this show
will they lean into it will they go
balls deep as it were
and to make sure that we make bones
about every single bit of their [__]
lies
well we'll find out I doubt it
if you want to you can come here and
watch maybe you'll get a dose of it
every single weekday
all right let's go to this uh Andrew
Tate clip oh my God
speaking of fragile men
oh my God these people want to be
oppressed about look at this is this is
this the guy that you look at like oh
man
total man oh look at the masculinity
dripping off this guy really honestly
this guy doesn't even have a chin
it looks like it in this picture because
he's you know he's shaped his facial
hair in a way that makes him look like
you have a gin but this guy doesn't even
have a chin doesn't have a chin and he's
supposed to be the picture of Matthew
Linney and then the other guy's sitting
on the other side let me show you a
preview here
there he is this guy is also supposed to
be the picture of masculinity Tucker
Carlson get the [__] out of here come on
man neither one of these idiots are the
picture of masculinity
okay
neither one of them and the crazy part
is is they think talking about how manly
they are and how oppressed they are
being men tanning their balls and
lifting weights they think that's what
makes them men
I'm not [__] you and they also oh
boy it's so hard to be a man listen to
this whining preaching this is another
thing that's very important I also think
as a man because life is a man is pain
and suffering I want
life of a man
is pain and suffering I could stop there
I could stop there and not show you any
more of this interview
and you would get the entire gist of the
interview it is a bunch of word salad
just like this about how they're
oppressed and how how tough men have to
be because how hard men got it
what the [__] out of here with this
nonsense listen this is a problem that
we have with these these [__] idiots
who don't get it
now the last the the great generation
during the second World War uh the
generation before them during the Civil
War and the first world war we have we
have the generation during the Vietnam
war they those men those men were forced
by a draft to go serve in their country
uh in the line of fire defend the
freedom forced to defend our freedom
forced to defend the Constitution kill
if need be
some of them suffering PTSD their entire
lives
but but the last two generations
are our military is voluntary it's
volunteers
did Tucker Carlson go and sign up and be
part of the military was he drafted no
no
he would never do that
he was living off the the fish tick this
fish stick trust fund
he would never get in the dream when
they would he would never say he would
want to draft
no hell no these men don't know what
manliness is they have no clue
and the reason why number one is because
they don't listen to women
they don't listen to women right because
they they base their entire masculinity
and manhood on impressing women
I'm my entire personality is to impress
a woman
whoosh well they're not impressed
when you're when you're doing that
they're not impressed I always like
watching these stupid videos
um unlike YouTube when they're like oh
yeah the thing that women are attracted
to is blank you know whatever whatever
it is they oh they they love broad
shoulders or they love when you have
money but listen listen to listen to
Andrew jadier he goes on about his word
salad and this is typical Andrew Tate
this is again
I want to explain this to you this is so
the dumbs think they're smart that's
what this this diatribe word salad of
Woe Is Me is let's listen to this when I
say that because
you're never going to be a good man or
good at being a man without pain and
suffering you're gonna have to go
through a bunch of CR of [__] and have a
terrible life to become a good man I
think okay that's ridiculous that you
have to have pain and suffering to be a
man like this thing where you have to
listen
he's telling this to Tucker Carlson who
has a
a fish stick trust fund he's a trust
fund baby Tucker Carlson never had to
work a day in his [__] life and he
would have been okay
he would have been fine never ran out of
money I mean he could have
but he could live a a well-to-do
lifestyle and never work a day in his
life the [__] out of here I should
embrace that and accept it and I think
that the the correct mental model for
men to have is a degree of stoicism and
not to be too concerned with even how
they feel if I woke up today happy if I
woke up today and happy I would have
done this interview with you if I woke
up today sad okay wait wait I want I
want to point out something this is very
important here this is very important to
this interview
okay very important
I want you to look down here at the
bottom here at the floor I want you to
see that these two ball tanners
these two masculine men
don't have socks on okay now I don't
know if Jill Biden set this trend but it
seems like a man thing
it seems like everyone on the internet
should be talking about how manly Joe
Biden is because he doesn't wear socks
right isn't this the sign of of [__]
masculinity where Tucker look how look
uh Tucker Carlson and these in these
khakis with these lopers
oh man I gotta zoom in on this later and
take a picture of this and you gotta
tell me what what pronouns wear these
shoes
wouldn't that piss him off I that's my
new favorite thing to do honestly I know
people say don't miss gender people
but I'll miss gender a bunch of [__]
fascists who misgender people
intentionally that's my new favorite
hobby is to go on Twitter and to
misgender these [__] fragile white
men Derek Evans have you heard of this
guy he's running for congress he was a
state he was a state representative he's
one of the January Sixers he went to
prison because he [__] tried to
overturn our national election now he's
running for congress this [__] little
[__] he's always he's always simping
for Trump and I'm always misgendering
him he hadn't paid attention yet but you
know that's how it goes I don't give a
[__] but yeah maybe I'll zoom in on this
um and and ask ask everyone on the
internet what gender you think wears
these these types of shoes here they're
they're kind of sexy you know what I
mean they're kind of sick Jesus Christ
why in the [__] did we hear about for
two goddamn days about how Joe Biden
went wearing socks are you kidding me
are you [__] [__] me Jesus Christ
I wouldn't even be pointing out that
they're not wearing socks I wouldn't
give a [__] if they were wearing socks
or not in this interview at those
[__] idiots weren't pointing out oh
look Joe Biden doesn't have shots on he
must forgot his socks he's he must be
cognitively impaired no he just wasn't
wearing socks man I don't wear socks
with all my shoes either like my hay
dudes I don't wear socks with them
they're loafers a lot of people don't
wear loafers socks with loafers it
happens even Tucker here let's listen I
would have done this interview with you
what's the difference why put so much
importance on my emotion if certain
things must be done I must work I must
train I must see Tucker Carlson
wait I might live wait me no have motion
we we cavemen we that's why that's why
me sex trafficker me sex trafficker
cause me have no emotion and because no
emotion me be man what
what the [__] are you talking about man
you you have you have more [__]
fragile emotions than anyone else on the
internet you get [__] triggered and
upset by all kinds of [__] [__] that
has nothing to do with you do you
remember the Greta thundberg thing how
he injected himself in the Greta
thundberg thing and then she just laid
it on him and the reason why they found
him on the charges for sex trafficking
and the rest of him in the first place
is because of a pizza box
remember this the pizza box that he was
using to own Greta thundberg to own a
woman a strong female figure in the
world what a dumb [__] the [__] out of
here Me Caveman me no have emotion I
must resist the Matrix I've got things
to do so I must resist the Matrix did
you hear that that's one of his things
well listen I must work I must train I
must see Tucker Carlson I must resist
the Matrix he said I must resist the
Matrix they really believe that [__]
they think there's some kind of like
[__] Matrix out there that's
controlling [__] they're wild man
they're nuttier and squirrel turds these
people who follow this this Andrew take
this sex trafficker Tucker Carlson he's
sex trash traffic or a Jason here but
let's listen I've got things to do so so
why are we gonna talk about how I feel
Tucker Carlson agrees that you should
avoid the Matrix that's how I act God
and as a man it shouldn't because
there's too much to do and the the
masculine world is hyper competitive
this is another thing most people don't
understand
yeah women want a few men at the top oh
yep that's what women want uh let's
let's listen to Andrew Tate tell us what
women want I'm sure I'm sure Andrew Tate
just got oh man he's probably got his
finger on the pulse of what women want
get the [__] out of here man the Ferrari
you you don't want a Ferrari that's it
that's Ferrari because all the men want
Ferrari and can't have one that's it
that's it women want a man listen listen
everyone out there in the audience
listen listen to me good according to
Andrew Tate what women want in the world
is a man who owns a Ferrari that's what
they want because that's the signal
that's the signal that they can go get a
bank loan for a Ferrari that's the
signal oh man now you talk about you
talk about
um manliness and masculinity and what
women want Andrew Tate knows it's a
Ferrari so if you listen if you're a
woman out there in the audience and it's
not exactly the Ferrari that you're
looking for for a man you're not doing
it correctly apparently according
to this masculine man
it's hyper competitive so if you're
competing against every other man for
every dollar you make every girl you see
the house
you're not going to be able to compete
with the person who performs regardless
of how they feel if you only compete
when you feel like competing
do you see what I mean do you see what I
mean when they when I say they try to
make this [__] complicated so the dumb
feels smart
do you see how you could you could see
these fragile these fragile white little
[__] incels listening to this guy go
yeah yeah exactly it's so hard to be a
man
right yet then that's the reason why I
don't have a woman it's not because I
hate women and I denigrate women it
couldn't be that it couldn't be that
it's just that I don't have a Ferrari
the [__] out of here ah what the [__]
let's continue because there's men like
me out there oh who will be sad every
day and I'll compete you regardless I
don't care how I feel I will still win
and that's the kind of mindset you need
to evolve
D oh let me tell you something let me
tell you something getting arrested for
sex trafficking
going to jail for sex trafficking let me
tell you something that's not winning
dude that's not [__] winning and
that's not attracting the the attention
of women either it's called sex
trafficking you're forcing them into sex
dummy
Jesus [__] Christ but this is this is
this is the the [__] the [__]
debut of fragile white men this is why
it's so easy for them to [__] take
the bait on this stupid [__] because
they they frame it up where the dumb
sounds smart Jordan Peterson does the
same thing Joe Rogan does the same thing
they do the same stupid [__]
where where they're the [__] victim
they're the fragile male victim they're
a bunch of [__] [__] is what they
are
it's ridiculous it's pathetic it's kind
of hilarious it really is fun to laugh
at them and mock them because really
honestly
if you sat down with I don't know any
normal people and just talk to like your
neighbors and your friends and I don't
know like your sister maybe your wife
your mom grandma and maybe a friend of
yours that's a female it's a woman maybe
if you just listen and listen to him you
would know that the one thing they're
not that they don't want is Andrew Tate
now you might think that that clip I
pulled from someone that were like oh
yeah that's not a that's a left-leaning
source that you pulled that from I
actually pulled that from
uh I pulled that from the
post-millennial which is Andrew knows
thing they posted that clip thinking
that that clip is the oh man this is
going to change at all
this clip is the [__]
it really shows how Andrew Tate is the
man well here is here's what I want to
tell you
I found this meme the other day
The Matrix is attacking me and then the
bunch of shills in cells on the internet
says this dude's a genius
so what's happening if you're wondering
if you're wondering why the internet is
a pile of sludge it's because a pile of
sludges like that and we're gonna stay
after him here every single weekday
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
I promise I'm gonna try to find that
guest co-host you guys gave me a good
list today what a great list you guys
came up with fantastic list you came up
with I'm gonna see if I can track down a
guest co-host for Friday for bonehead of
the week so don't forget to follow us on
Twitter why it still exists at Tony
Michaels pod because you can vote for
bonehead of the week there
I hope they get polls on threads soon as
soon as they get pulls on threads I'm
not going to do the poll on Twitter
anymore we'll just do it on threads so
you're gonna want to get a threads
account if you like to do the bonehead
of the week here's the other secret
about the bonehead of the week you can
do the poll on the Tony Michaels podcast
Community page here on YouTube just
click subscribe you'll get that poll
tomorrow tomorrow you'll get the poll on
YouTube and on Twitter
and maybe maybe I'll maybe I'll do a
poll today
of who you want to be the guest host I
don't know maybe we'll do that we'll
have some fun with it also follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
watch us for free over there live every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific also
on Twitch make sure hey I've got a few
more here look at this uh we've got one
two three more people than have
resubscribed with their Amazon Prime
account on Twitch thank you very much
six months three months three months
damn you guys are you guys are getting
it getting it going on over there now
here's what happens with twitch if you
go to Twitch twitch.com the Tony
Michaels you can follow us for free but
if you want to link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account you can
give us that one free subscription that
you get with your Amazon Prime account
and you can use it to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast it doesn't cost a
single extra dime of your Prime account
what it does is we get a couple dollars
of Amazon's money and it doesn't cost
you a single nickel so go to
thetonymichaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you'll find
the directions there's the fourth button
down also you'll find my new threads
account I put it at the top I think it's
right after
where you link the Amazon Prime account
and the twitch count I believe that's
where the threads link is so go follow
me on threads as well you're not going
to want to miss a thing and if you
haven't downloaded that app yet
go do that you you don't I don't think
you have to have an Instagram but it
works better if you have one I believe
so get your Instagram account or if you
have an Instagram account get a threads
account go follow me just go to the Tony
michaels.com you can find all the links
there uh also also do not forget to go
uh to what was that show.com that's what
was thatshow.com uh support Gabe Sanchez
what a great Episode by Gabe with the
Marjorie Taylor green today I'm glad we
get to get your gate fixed today here on
the Tony Michaels podcast even though he
wasn't able to join us I don't know if
you'll join us the rest of the week
again he's kind of out of pocket where
he's at the internet doesn't work quite
as well I he was in Tucker's he was in
Tucker's Studio the last few days but
he's moved to a different spot so I
don't I don't know if the internet's
gonna work for him to um
to have him on the show he he's earned
it though he's earned to go have a
little bit of fun and hang out and and
take a breather we all we all need that
every once in a while we all need some
reprieve so we'll see if we can get a
guest dose for you today also visit
store.dtonymichaels.com that
store.thetonymichaels.com next week
don't forget next week I think we're
gonna do hat week so if you're if you're
looking for [__] em hats wait till next
week I'm telling you wait till next week
I think we're gonna do a hat week next
week I'm so glad you joined me I'm so
glad you stayed with me today here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
until tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
IL born head ass Beacon